bien que tu es super mais j'en ai enfin
j'ai vu plein de stars qui se comportent
très mal questionnent très mal à la
table
bonjour my Wayne
donc de la comédienne et journaliste
Catherine Belkhodja votre père
guitariste classique breton c'est que
vous appelez Maïwenn avec votre sœur
s'appelle isilde c'est pour ça que vous
appelez le Besco vous grandissez à
Belleville dans un trois pièces assez
bordélique
oui
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai vous avez été
chez moi
c'est qu'il y avait pas de porte
c'est vrai et donc je pouvais pas
prendre de douche et vous l'aviez pas
souvent
alors il y avait votre mère vos frères
vos soeurs un bordel monstre et l'été
vous partiez à Alger passer les vacances
dans la maison de vos grands-parents
maternels voilà et alors c'est terrible
avec vous moi je savais pas du tout
cette histoire c'est que dès le départ
votre mère a voulu faire de vous une
star
dès l'âge de 3 ans vous montez la sur
les planches
à 4 ans en fait vos débuts au cinéma à 5
ans en fait à Jenny jeûne dans l'été
meurtriers voilà donc c'est votre mère
qui vous poussait à faire tout ça
c'était une obligation comme quand on
doit aller à l'école je faisais ça parce
que voilà je me posais pas la question
si jamais aussi j'aimais pas je le
faisais parce que ça faisait partie de
la vie évidemment scolarité assez
chaotique alors pour pas énerver votre
mère les profs qui vous faisaient passer
dans la classe au-dessus non c'est ma
mère qui faisait tout un cirque pour me
faire passer oui
mais vous vous pas pu me faire passer
elle m'a pris à la maison elle me fait
faire l'école par correspondance
alors évidemment à l'école je tiens un
petit peu la tête de turque vous étiez
un peu la tête de turc la grande maigre
qui était toujours un peu à l'écart
à vous tirer les cheveux
m'oblige à me mettre en mini-jupe elle
m'oblige à me tenir droite comme un
piquet à mettre les seins en avant
mais en même temps je savais pas trop ce
que je voulais faire je suivais juste le
mouvement ma mère ne m'aimait qu'à
travers un écran de cinéma voilà
c'est
destiné très très très particulière
alors évidemment votre mère elle met
tous les moyens pour faire de vous une
star elle vous fait faire de
l'équitation de l'anglais de la Danse de
l'Opéra enfin elle m'a fait passer
l'examen de l'Opéra de Paris et j'étais
pas absolument pas préparée donc je me
suis retrouvé avec plein de petits rats
le jour de l'examen qui connaissait
toutes les positions qui faisaient grand
écart et tout moi je m'étais pas lavé
depuis bon Vincent j'étais assez grade
et
les jours de l'examen la prof m'a
demandé bah alors allez-y montrez-nous
et je crois que je suis allé faire
première position deuxième troisième et
elle m'a dit écoutez je d'abord vous
êtes pas propre mais je vous conseille
de faire autre chose que de l'avance
vous avez vos règles à 9 ans
vous mesurez déjà un mètre 75
extrêmement précoce on vous appelle la
girafe
et alors vous commencez vous commencez
les Bains Douches à 12 ans
un jour que le chat il m'a dit mais
alors toi tu as quel âge j'ai les mêmes
j'ai 12 ans il fait un
puis vous aviez des jeans dans un sac je
m'étais mon jean dans mon sac jusqu'au
jour où on s'est rendu compte que
j'avais mon jean
vous gagnez un concours de mannequin
pour le magazine 20 Ans et vous
commencez à faire des films vous faites
la gamine avec Johnny Hallyday
non je raconte ça parce que quand
l'attaché de presse Gilles Paquet Dieu
et son âme vous demande d'aller chez
Foucault pour faire la promotion du film
vous refusez d'y aller oui parce que
qui rend pas les gens mais pas les gens
en valeur j'avais pas envie de
m'entendre dire alors Maïwenn nous avait
vous avez 15 ans qu'est-ce que ça fait
de tourner avec Johnny Hallyday j'avais
pas envie d'entendre ça donc j'ai pas
voulu la faire et puis j'ai le paquet
m'a dit bah écoute moi en 20 ans j'ai
jamais entendu ça ou tu fais Foucault et
tout ou tu ne fais rien
je suis désolée j'ai pas envie de faire
Foucault
j'ai fait un peu de promo les gens qui
arrivaient à me joindre de leur côté
mais avec Johnny
et alors là c'est là où arrive dans
votre vie un événement très important
cette année-là donc en 91 Anne Paris ou
à son César et Luc Besson pleure
évidemment parce qu'il voit à Paris ou
qui sont César et évidemment Maïwenn
vous tendez le mouchoir que vous aviez
dans la poche à Luc Besson et c'est le
début
c'était dans les chiottes déjà
[Rires]
émue de l'avoir émue et de lui de le
voir ému que je me suis mise à pleurer
et à bégayer de dire je suis contente
vous et puis ils sont mis tous les deux
à me donner la main et ils étaient trop
mignon et puis tous les deux une grande
histoire d'amour entre Luc Besson
je sais tout mais pas tout finalement
non d'accord vous avez 15 ans il a 32
ans
comme ça au moins si tu veux c'est clair
quand on demande la permission on a une
chance sur deux de s'entendre répondre
non exactement là au moins il y avait
pas de souci et là pendant 6 ans on vous
voit plus le silence radio pour la
première fois de votre vie vous soufflez
un peu vous êtes obligé de travailler
pour vivre quoi
en banque jusqu'à 18 ans
j'ai pas envie de travailler du tout
j'avais pas envie de faire l'actrice et
vous faites un enfant avec Besson et
vous dites j'étais plus prête à 16 ans à
faire un enfant que lui à 30 quand même
moi j'avais ça au moins depuis gamine je
m'étais dit je veux avoir un enfant
c'est tellement bizarrement dans ma
famille je m'étais dit quand ça sera ma
famille
et là vous partez à Beverly Hills
pour Dior pour Madonna pour Sting non
j'ai fait des pâtes pour bien que
et puis bio qui était super mais j'en ai
enfin j'ai vu plein de stars qui se
comportent très mal qui se tiennent très
mal à la table alors vous tournez dans
le cinquième élément vous aurez dans le
5e élément et quand le film sort vous
êtes déjà pu avec lui pas très longtemps
après je tiens
[Rires]
total
qui s'appelle de Belleville Beverly
Hills
qui sortent parce que ça parlait de
Belleville
et la fin du bouquin était pour Beverly
Hills et puis je suis arrivée un jour
dans la maison d'édition je vais pas
dire le nom et j'ai vu une pré maquette
de mon bouquin ils avaient mis une photo
de moi qui ressemblait à une et
puis ils avaient mis des belles villes à
Beverly ils sont tout petits et en
dessous ou l'amour du cinquième élément
j'ai dit c'est quoi là pourquoi j'ai
changé le titre à ma place
il faut ça parle d'amour votre livre moi
mon livre il parle de couscous de
boulettes et Belleville ça va pas parler
de star je vais pas vous lâcher des
potins quoi donc je me suis dit je
préfère pas le faire plutôt que et là
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez mis dans
votre spectacle c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est-à-dire de toute cette histoire que
je viens d'essayer de raconter qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui vous avez mis dans
votre spectacle de toutes ces de tous
ces petits faits qu'on vient de voir là
je parle pas de Luc à un moment là parce
que c'était pas drôle j'ai essayé
j'avais fait une partie Luc
ça se passe sur la période 12 quand j'ai
12 ans jusqu'à 15 ans jusqu'au moment où
je pars c'est la période où je sors ou
ma mère me fasse ça sortir et il y a pas
qu'elle il y a mon père il y a un agent
me force à sortir
de la gare tous les lundis à quelle
heure 22h je vous ai vu dans Paris
dernière dire que vous aimiez les filles
désormais vous embrassez les filles
j'ai embrassé deux filles cet été
[Applaudissements]
je voulais vraiment sentir ce que ça
faisait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention interlude si on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
je t'ai préparé pour l'interview
première fois merde je suis imprévisible
quand même c'est comme les gens qui
viennent ici pour la première fois ils
avaient l'interview première fois
pareil c'était préparé pour des
interviews avec des préservatifs des
machins des trucs j'ai fait le
questionnaire de prousse avec des fautes
de français heureusement qu'il y avait
Jamel pour l'aider à faire des fautes de
français est-ce que vous êtes mytho pas
du tout vous êtes mégalo
je le suis oui un jour je suis plus
qu'un jour je suis
sage un jour je suis studiante
six mois rien du tout
alors pas encore est-ce que vous êtes
maso
non pas du tout
géronto
jusqu'à quel âge ça marche cette
question 50 ans 51 c'est plutôt à quel
âge a commencé
[Applaudissements]
je l'ai essayé alors
[Musique]
tu sais qu'elle est dans un triple hyper
romantique quoi en ce moment la
productrice de l'émission qui s'étonne
que vous ayez jamais essayé
je suis vraiment désolée
je m'excuse
est-ce que vous êtes homo Maïwenn
est-ce que vous êtes est-ce que vous
êtes est-ce que vous êtes homo
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de fille cet été c'est tout
ça vous a pas suffisamment plus pour
continuer
est-ce que vous êtes Rocco
c'est pas la taille qui change
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu